[Music]
oh
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
support the fight go buy some
merchandise at the shop
it's a great conversation starter and
irritates
all the right people.com
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
strangers
yeah it's wonderful that was called i
know something you don't know sip
oh mysterious oh so glad to be with you
we have uh we have a big ass show today
we have donald trump jr in the show wow
son of the president i know what you
think hunter was not available because
it was the annual
wisconsin cheese fest wow yeah well you
never know
it's a lot to smoke yeah he's a shitty
man it's a brilliant way
to just have your drugs hidden in plain
sight just show up to a packers game of
course
and then make some art right and uh of
course we're gonna be talking we have a
full unedited tape here today of uh
what uh went down with the h3h3
oh no because there were there were many
because there were many surprises
and we'll be talking about transgenders
at the olympics oh well that's a lot of
fun
and taking your chats but first gerald a
how are you sir i am
angry really yes well okay there's
stupidity abounds well just make sure
that if you're angry you know you um
when you transform it the pants don't
rip they never do
they never do that yeah they're stretchy
stretchy stretchy purple jeans which
begs some other questions hulk i'm sorry
banana
quarter black carrot how are you i'm
ready to watch a show i'm ready to watch
the show as well
and we have dave linda you have a show
coming up this weekend ahoy yes i do
i will be in buffalo new york at helium
and i do want to throw this in real
quick
the first and second of july i will be
at big l's in minnesota emily minnesota
he's a huge fan of the show big l is
big big l's oh big ow i have that
terrible michigan accent
do you think his do you think when his
parents named him big al they intended
for him to be a prison rapist
i think so well i guess you hope you go
with alex but then it can either turn
into like oh he's like peak heating or
he's a rapist
right yes exactly either one um so i'm
looking forward to we're gonna get to
some of the uh h3 stuff in a little bit
and uh well first though let's just
watch this the san francisco gay men's
chorus
is it choir gay men's chorus it's the
chorus i think it's a chorus
i guess the vienna boys choir has the
corner on that they don't
use the term choir yeah they just took
it from we like other men's bots
obtained
sir so this is the san francisco gay
men's chorus
uh this is uh more again these people
are all taking the role of being
glorified advertisers for big pharma
wanting you to get vaccinated
they don't understand that they look
like the north korean army in that
square
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i'm sure getting pricked with something
one of them
now let's do one about condoms
we got serena williams in the payroll oh
that's great i think that's her sister
how about hiv what gets rid of that
not the not the group session they're
going to have after that chorus session
that looks like the beginning of the
prison scene from human centipede 3 when
then
no it looks like we have a picture of
that square that's exactly what it looks
like
vaccinate and fouchy's dear leader
whatever she says
also fouchy got 12 uh holes in one in
his first game of golf ah
whoa don't question it wow uh so uh by
the way we're uh
just so you know the show the best thing
you can do is just tune in it's a live
show
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
and you can subscribe to the podcast
audio you know because we don't know how
long we're on youtube we're on
apple android spotify all that stuff i'd
like to remove us for
no apparent reason yeah and uh you know
well i'll get to the question later but
first off do you think
that gensake is a demon straight from
the pits of hell possibly
because we have likely we have some
proof
so yesterday uh a fly landed on on
jinsaki
during a press conference you've
probably seen this was it the pence fly
well first let me say we've made
tremendous progress uh in our
vaccination efforts to date
no go ahead thanks i think there's a fly
on your head
thank you oh thank you guys at least
it's not a cicada i swear those things
are okay
okay i don't know what you said we're
supposed to eat the cicadas now yeah
what's up with cicada do you see your
tongue go out to try to eat it well
actually this is the one thing we have
the exclu we isolated the audio and
zoomed in and this is something a lot of
people missed because because they shoot
in a 30 frame rate right right right
sure so we got
a 60. yeah sometimes you can catch it
and yeah we have the exclusive here
thanks i think there's a fly on your
head thank you
oh thank you guys at least it's not a
cicada i swear those things are
wow she is skilled
wow that is accuracy i thought
chopsticks you know with mr miyagi
catching was
yeah it's good no that's yogi ain't got
nothing it's not it's the lizard people
[Laughter]
we know this oh no yes sir
regret to inform you work for demented
old circus monkey
i either fry gain one more freckle
people don't remember that that was
really like they think of karate kid
there were some really really touching
scenes in that there were yeah
and that one was where he was drunk
talking about how he lost his wife it
was unbelievable
oh yeah and we had ralph macchio on the
show i remember talking with him i
thought
it was some of the best acting that i'd
seen as far as someone who was an adult
playing a teenager when he was saying i
just want to go home
i want to go home to new york i never
asked him about that and
you could see he was he was touched
because i think a lot of people you know
it sort of became campy
yeah and remembered what karate kid was
sort of known for the iconic poster yeah
the guy really had some acting chops
yeah how old was he when he did that
i think he was like 54. yeah she's up
there
i like how the whole movie is advanced
that whole movie is just mr miyagi who
is in fact a drunk
uh trying to make is to make this boy do
his housework
yeah yeah you wax my car he's like this
is karate he's like yeah
go cut my lawn with your shirt off right
now don't worry i'll teach you a crazy
japanese tape wax on and must have put
the
johnson up baby oil oh is that a is that
a fact sensei
pat do a crane kick which
no one will see coming yeah exactly
other than i
love that that entire thing of like oh
it might be kicking you but you know
whatever
it was all right guys we have other
stories we have to move on by the way
hit the notification bell because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
so on the youtube notification bell
you'll you'll know when the show is
which is
monday through thursday at 10am eastern
um here's a new poll
by the way the for the people act uh
monmouth university poll so
the senate they're scheduled to hold a
procedural vote on the for the people
act yeah
let me just re just recap this for you
because we did a whole segment on it i
think you can go and search
you can't on youtube but if you go to
liverpool.com right now if you search on
youtube
voting act or for the people act crowder
you find an old
pbs video with 400 plays nice
so uh let me just sort of give you
a recap of it so we don't have to go
into a whole deep dive and you can find
this at congress.gov or we'll have the
link in the description um this forces
states this bill to
allow same-day registration it mandates
and expands early voting mandates no
excuse absentee voting
it bans identification requirements for
obtaining absentee ballots and it forces
states to accept sworn
affidavits instead of identification
isn't it funny that sworn affidavits are
enough
now when hundreds as it related to the
uh election which by the way of course
no evidence ever that there's ever been
any kind of voter fraud that's gonna
happen to youtube we just wanna be very
clear
but all of the sworn affidavits the
hundreds that claimed that it had
uh well that's just a sworn affidavit
who really cares and at this point it's
like uh
how do i know that you live there i do
good enough for me
go in and determine the fate of our
constitutional republic sir
exactly so how do you plan on securing
the election um we are going to depend
on people
to be truthful yeah that's stupid
it just makes common sense we are going
to depend on people
to do the right thing yeah did you watch
that vaccinate gay chorus video
have you been paying attention at all to
society i absorbed it
whoa by osmosis yes it was forced
it was sticky there was a recent poll
come on
there was a recent poll uh from mon
mouth university yeah
on early voting and id and this is
something we've talked about how the
majority of black people support voting
id
we didn't change your mind on this
voting id once you sort of get down to
the nitty-gritty it's very hard for
people to argue against it but e
and i don't think that policy should be
dictated by polls right
however when the policy is entirely
predicated right what have the
what is the left been saying the
republicans want to make sure that you
can't vote
if you're young if you're a woman if
you're lgbtq
and specifically if you're not white
well okay hold on a second so you really
have no basis for saying that we
shouldn't have any voter identification
it's not in line with really anywhere
else in the modern industrialized world
it's predicated on but it's popular
that's the only reason that i'm
addressing the poll right now
vast majority of americans support voter
id 84
of minorities versus 77 percent of white
people
wow you can't find 84 percent of
minorities and 77 percent of white
people to agree on
anything that's a pretty big number
right now especially a republican policy
it's just it's the most benign thing
ever to say hey you got to show an idea
if you got to show an idea to check out
a book you got to show an idea to vote
what's hard about that put a room
together with 84 black people
77 white people and see if you can get
them to agree
on dinner or the show afterward that's
true none of it but i want to go to the
apollo i would like to go to the opera
but uh do we think that we should all
have to present identification well yeah
should you
no obviously we're not monsters and
there's just one guy who's beaten to
death because he suggested medea
[Laughter]
you ain't black we're like we all can
agree it was just scary yeah
which one yeah well i mean which i don't
think it matters
there's so many i'm sure they're all
different in many ways so
let me let me ask this i have a few
questions for you today the best thing
you can do is just
just comment below and uh smash that
like button if you're watching this live
hit the like button
and comment there are only a few
um sort of topics of discussion
where i haven't even heard a valid
argument from the other side
now i understand for example i don't
agree with it but i understand the
arguments when you talk about abortion
and people haven't really done their due
diligence so they don't know
they just say they don't think that life
begins at fertilization but they don't
really know when life begins right
i understand that as it comes to taxes
you have people who say well you know
what people need to
pay their fair share i don't agree with
it and statistically i don't agree with
obviously the outcome because we sort of
know we've talked about hauser's law
we've talked about the laffer curve
but i understand people's argument there
are two
that i've never heard something even
close to a valid argument against
one of which i've talked about is school
choice or at the very least a voucher
which is attached to the student that
means that instead of spending twelve
thousand dollars per pupil
at a school where they have to go with
no choice you attach it to the student
and they can take it wherever they want
never heard an argument against it
that's anything even close to remotely
convincing
i've only heard people say well that
would be racist the other one is and you
can comment below
because i want to know i want to know
what i'm missing here
i've never heard anything close to
something resembling a valid argument as
to why you
shouldn't need to present identification
to vote
other than it's racist is there is there
an argument out there that i'm that i'm
missing
yeah i haven't seen any does anyone here
can anyone think of anything i want to
make sure
that racist is the only thing that i've
heard yeah but then 84
of black people are like nah like i got
an idea actually what are you talking
about they get offended when you tell
them that
you're you're not smart enough as joe
biden would say probably because he said
this about other things to get an id
no he said i know it was just just as
capable people as white kids right as
smart smart as white kids but how in the
world do you think that it's impossible
for somebody to get an id
it's an obvious ploy to make sure that
illegal people who are here
not not legally get to vote right right
and if they've taken your license for
some
reason you can actually get an
identification card
well there are a lot of forms of id that
they would be worth to accept for almost
well in most states
nothing for free yeah and the average
price is like 12 yeah yes
unless you want the park recreation oh
wait no that's not no no no
but i love how when biden said that it's
clear like he was it's like an
affirmation he was saying it take a
vince
himself yeah no black kids are just as
capable they're just as capable as white
kids
yeah joe black kids are just as capable
was it black kids or was it poor kids
poor kids poor kids they're one of the
same and come on in my mind you know the
show
like there's no poor white poor kids are
just as capable as white kids
black kids poor kids
yeah we all know what he meant it was
thinly veiled i think i can i think
oh oh well look for the people who were
scared about
made up interference yeah russians
interfering with the election how about
this
how about we just let a couple hundred
thousand russians vote in our election
yeah not show id let's just let's i
understand you you want to take the
focus off people from south america okay
fine
let's let a couple hundred thousand
russians who are not citizens of the
united states that would be the
equivalent of you saying
nobody needs to show id and we're
actually having people without id
vote next thing is we just have a tarp
for vodka and nightclubs
hey i'm glad you changed your system i
like to party
yeah i'm a real [ __ ] but have a very
hair trigger
you never know what's gonna happen only
that i show up in matching tracksuit
come to my house i have indoor outdoor
pool you start swimming inside but you
finish out the side did you look at my
cousin dressed sexy
why are you so mad if i want to hit on a
girl that's my cousin
this is my cousin oh she is so sexy
almost like giant crystal elephant by
the way you see my giant crystal
elephant
i drove here what is it with like
serbians and those when they come to the
united states it's just
so gaudy if they make money i think yeah
i think they just have
like in their countries there's they
have two posters one is run dmc
and the other one is a white bmw
that is how i live my life this is the
american dream right yes
gold chain track suit white bmw they go
to the dealer like hey hey can we
maybe we do tires can we put in like
nail in
jewels like well that wouldn't really
work it's just like having a nail in
your tire but if we never take it out
hey about the bedazzle can you bedazzle
the tires
that's it okay so uh here's where
so a lot of people have we're gonna be
talking about this this is something i'm
looking forward to
uh you might remember that uh you know
there was a little spat with you guys
remember with the h3 ethan klein
and he was a he's a youtube creator okay
and uh
he made the comment i think we've had it
on our sound board that you should do
exactly what the cdc tells you this
government agency you don't even have to
think about it you don't have to think
about it dude
right and so again the point there was
criticizing the idea i think that's
really bad yes that's really bad to tell
an audience of young impressionable
youth that they shouldn't do their own
due diligence
right that they shouldn't actually try
and aggregate information and
come to an informed rational um decision
well of course you can as long as you
can back up what you're saying
right yes as long as you can back up
what you're yeah so there were some
videos kind of going back and forth and
you guys know i i really don't like
doing the
the youtube drama the pissing contest uh
but um and for what i understand he
released a portion of this clip
yesterday but
not everything oh of course um
interestingly ethan klein then and
afterward when i said on air that i
would love to have a conversation with
him
reached out to me yeah to debate okay he
reached out to me directly on twitter
um but first let me let me kind of set
some context here too because there are
some
uh ill-conceived notions you know
changed my mind is very different from a
debate okay we've done many changed my
minds but i've also done
a lot of debates not even including what
i had to do on fox news and cnn and hln
when i worked there for years
i changed my mind the whole goal to
change my mind for example is an
anti-debate
where people aren't just trying to score
points where people aren't in a you know
you know in a quadrant view where they
each have three minutes it's almost like
you say this
every single change well the whole thing
is yeah the point to change my mind was
i used to sit down we'd have these great
conversations right
at the gym or i'd have them you know at
a restaurant or we'd have them in the
studio
and i thought why can't this go on air
yeah and so that's what changed my mind
um became and that being said it changed
my
me we've also had professors sit down
which very admirable because
most of them um refuse to it's it's
basically changed my mind
is the ones that we do on campus because
about 40 50
of them are actually not on campus it's
just anywhere in a city where we can get
a permit
um it's supposed to be done in
classrooms
right that's the point yeah but it's not
taking place so
because we've talked about it radical
one-sidedness at college okay
now on the flip side of that i've done
many debates
right throughout my career i think we
have some uh thumbnails here so you guys
can kind of see
uh you have you know you have mayors you
have actors you have comedians you have
columnists for new york times you have
scientists feminists
you have feminists you have cnn hosts uh
green is in there and then um of course
i've also even done these debates
ironically devil's advocate
yeah where i've argued from the point of
the left against people like uh like ben
shapiro against people like uh jordan
peterson
uh tim poole john stossel that was fun
he's a little
a little prickly i see what you're
trying to do here with your little
character
give me a break stance of the question
um so i just wanted to set this so you
understand kind of where we've been with
this show for a while
and when ethan klein reached out to me
to have a debate on uh on twitter
um i think we have the uh the
screenshots here right yeah we have the
screenshots where he reached out to me
and said that he wanted to do a debate
just him and i yeah i said okay so what
will it be
i agree to the terms of uh the debate i
said look we'll talk about the covet
issue because
yeah cdc that was the initial uh that
was the initial topic of discussion we
can talk about big tech because now he
supports big tech censorship
then there was some email i don't know
if you had the emails there there were
some emails that again went back and
forth
where they said hey what do you want to
do we'll get on a call it'll just be
you and i just you and i no tricks very
clear about that right
right because every time the reason i
mention these other debates is every
time we've had a debate with someone
been very straightforward i disagree
with you this is the topic we're going
to cover
right and one of the reasons you say
it's just going to be uni it's like i'm
not going to be sitting over here on my
computer trying to pull up something to
kind of do a gacha moment yeah right and
you've always told me that like hey if
we're
debating somebody you can always come in
let me introduce you and let them know
you're never going to surprise somebody
blind sides yes and you've debated uh
real comedians that are great like
christopher titus yes
not whatever that is well
um and to be clear i would debate noam
chomsky tomorrow all he has to say is
yes
but he doesn't owe it to me my kind of
general rule is look it has to be
someone who's an expert in something
someone who's really worthy or it has to
be a comparable audience otherwise you
end up debating every time dick and
harry
so this was supposed to happen with with
ethan klein
and what i'm about to show you is the
unedited master clip
of uh me coming in for a sound check
yeah beforehand
and the conversation that i had with
ethan look i want you to understand
something too
what you're about to see sort of behind
the scenes is very genuine right
um i really did wish him the best with
his with his uh new baby
yeah and his family and his wife and i
really did
plan to come on and have this
conversation in good faith
uh with ethan it really wasn't an act
and you'll see how it is with any other
debate and that's what i had hoped would
happen here but i never
actually thought it would happen
and i know you're saying well it's easy
to go back in monday morning quarterback
that you know afterward
but uh all along i kind of expected
ethan to be
sort of i wanted him to be a good guy
you try and speak people and elevate
them to who you want to be but
at a certain point you know cowardice is
cowardice and my greatest my greatest
problem honestly here when you're about
to watch this is is um
if sam cedar who pops up who's sort of
ancillary
really the issue is um is ethan's wife
because it's your job to try and beat
the cowardice out of your husband
because you're gonna have a little bit
you're gonna have a little boy
right that's the thing when you have a
son you have to make sure that they
understand what integrity is and yeah
for me a man makes an agreement and a
man is good to his word
yeah this really comes down to an
agreement good to your word and i know
you always have two signs who kind of
claim your side wins but
really there's only one side that's
based on a lie and i just
i wish it didn't happen because i really
wanted to talk to him about his his
relationship with susan wojcicki and
flip and the support of big tech because
also keep in mind too i had to navigate
some murky waters here
because the goal was to remove me from
medical misinformation any conversations
about covet ethan has talked about that
in the past so now
without uh without further delay um
in its full context a little bit of a
surprise
the debate with ethan klein
yeah because this mic hasn't been
adjusted guys
hold on let me adjust this because i
have to set it to
human height since dave is doing it i
can see some weird contact thing there
let me check this check one two three
good all right okay you guys are gonna
call him and sound check him yeah
i uh i bet this guy's gonna do anything
he can
to avoid actually debating
yeah i think he wants to do anything
that he possibly can do but
let me know yeah i mean i don't know
when you want me to admit him into the
room i'll just do it sure well
yeah i'll just say you guys do the sound
checking i don't want to sit there and
talk with their producer dan and stuff
but
i don't think this guy wants to do this
i wouldn't be surprised of you
he's probably gonna bring someone else
on who's his producer like a fan of that
uh
cedar character yeah that'd be my bet
but hey hopefully he man's up okay you
can do your sound check
all righty here we go i'm gonna sit
right here while you guys
okay all right
hey guys can you hear us
hello hey how's it going
you hear a swell or oh yeah i can hear
you just fine
perfect you and you yeah you guys sound
good
okay great who am i speaking with
uh this is producer tim tim yes
hi tim nice to meet you nice to meet you
are you one of the guys that dresses up
in the crowd or are you not on
on uh on screen
i'm running the audio board okay are you
okay so you're not the peter pan guy or
anything like that
peter pan no no hold on one second
we'll get stephen here momentarily okay
thank you
oh dave's leave food crumbs on this
thing it's like a crescent moon of
filth hi stephen hey ethan how you doing
brother
hey i just want to say on a serious note
that i'm glad you're um
your wife is okay i heard you had a
little bit of a yeah
with your wife well she's uh she's
pregnant with twins so yeah
it's like uh well by the way
congratulations too i know you guys are
thank you
in the same process it's a whole thing
they they they've switched
down a little bit oh sorry am i too loud
for you uh
i just told dan our producer to turn the
volume down a little bit you're good to
take out my gum yeah yeah they switch
and they breach
and so uh she's rolling around yeah
yeah i mean at first they said c-section
and they said oh we might be able to do
a natural birth but they often do
c-section and then they said oh yeah and
then it's no wait now the other one's
breached and
the boy is just a dick he just will not
stop kicking the other one it's like a
i would say it's like a junior suite
apartment he keeps kicking the girl and
so then the girl wakes up so
oh yeah so how how far in is she
she's due uh late july early august oh
wow that's coming right up
yeah and i've got a big surgery july 1st
so i'm trying to get everything done in
a
in a hurry is that your first it is
uh yeah it is yeah we talked about in
the show quite a bit my wife so my wife
had a basic operation for um
but i won't talk about it she probably
won't but basically then she woke up
with something called gbs
um so we kind of wasn't really fertility
issues it was a physical issue
and gbs actually paralyzes you from the
waist down
so that's what she was experiencing yeah
when she came out just because i put her
under and
and so it's interesting like you know
i'm i'm like
a pro-vaxxer generally speaking but she
can't even get a flu shot it's one of
the few conditions because of the gbs
it's like a neurological condition
where she has to be careful with any
vaccine so it's just been a weird
navigation but this is your second right
yeah this is gonna be our second so
we've been we've been through it
yeah but uh and it's just one it was
supposed to be three but they
the one child cannibalized everyone and
he has gained their uh
their energies to become the ultimate
human being
i feel like that's what happens with the
uh that's what happened with the olsen
twins i'm convinced that one of them is
evil
and one of them ate the third one yeah
something happened there well it seems
like whenever you see them in pictures
there's one who's more disturbing
but maybe you're right but all right man
well i pre i appreciate you coming on
and doing this and you know doing this
uh
a lot of people don't so just talking
you know avoiding kind of the social
media pissing contest drama
um so uh yeah are you ready ready to go
so i just want to make one clarification
so
in terms of so we're both going to
record it and then we can use it
wherever we want on your show on my show
whatever right yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah and we can send you
the file if we want because we have the
master file everything so
yeah we're i think we're good right dan
we're recording it on our end okay okay
yeah we've never used zoom either we we
uh did you ever get sold on that skype
tx box remember when that came out
oh no i dude i've always had such a pain
with skype that i um
zoom has always been really good so well
the skype tx box
is like from new tech i think and they
sold us on that they said this is what
jimmy kimmel uses and all these people
and
well skype tx it's like a box that's
it's almost like remember the comments
boxes no it sucks what we've had to do
is we just have mac minis
set up and we've skype has played well
with those but not the exclusively
designed
skype tx box that we paid whatever
premium yeah skype i don't trust skype
skype has always sucked yeah all right
well um
i'll just uh oh and then so so um
okay so we're gonna record it and um and
then the topics
are just like uh just we said um
about authority with the vaccine and um
there was something else you mentioned i
don't know how well i just thought
yeah however you want to do it i thought
that since that was kind of the subject
that
yeah that got us into a tiff that we
could talk about sort of the cdc sort of
you know medical authorities and
yeah tell me where you disagree with me
and then also um kind of big tech
because that ties in you know with the
cdc world health organization
and uh okay i'll just sort of i'll
introduce it to my
you know i have a little bit of a
different audience to let them know kind
of who you are what's going on and if
you want to do the same that's fine but
uh yeah yeah yeah of course of course
we'll let them know
all right okay and uh so all right i'll
give you a countdown and then i'll uh
three two
all right okay i'm really glad to have
my next guest on the show and i've
always said this i always respect people
who um
enter the enter into the arena um and
you know we've had a lot of debates on
this show which is different from like
it changed my mind where we sit down
have conversations
but old brazilian jiu jitsu coach said
if you come switch
we'll go switch you go spicy we're going
to do a little spicy
so we always try and uh keep it as
respectful as possible and i really do
appreciate the guy making the time
because a lot of people haven't
has a huge youtube channel several
youtube channels one of the ogs
a lot of people watch them uh you know
some of you like them
some of you don't same can be said for
me ethan klein from h3h3
uh ethan thanks man for making the time
you're very welcome and i just want to
say i know you called me you said that i
would be a layup
i think i used something like that yeah
and i think you're right because i don't
think i'm a very good debater
i think you know that so uh i didn't
want to make it too easy for you
oh okay so i've prepared
okay yes all right so what we were going
to talk about
is uh what we were going to talk about
is you know the initial quote that
happened
i think he's looking off there uh the
initial quote that kind of was turned
into
um a little bit of a meme which wasn't
intentional
and uh was you saying you don't even
have to think about it
regarding the cdc uh and i disagree with
that
um i think people should think about it
i believe and we
talked about this through playful
ribbing in an aggregation of medical
authorities and scientific voices
to make an informed and rational
decision um so where do you think that i
was
that i'm wrong on that stephen do you
know that
um the spartans are
that they are like uh practice man love
with children oh jeez okay so this is
what's gonna happen i
what did i tell you he was gonna do
anything he could to avoid oh
oh there he is oh no sam cedar what a
what what a [ __ ] nightmare thank you
steven
i had no idea this was going to happen i
thought i thought ethan was a stand-up
guy
this is where we are yeah dave dave
remember i told you i told you
i said this i guarantee you he's going
to do anything he can to avoid the
debate
i just think he believes that he should
debate you no no he doesn't he just
takes advantage of of women with you
know mental health issues
ethan doesn't stand up and do his own
fighting i gotta say
let's bring on fm that you would
uh do anything to avoid talking to me i
think you're
the point include joe rogers yeah joe
rogan
and dave rubin and jordan peterson and
noam chomsky
and sam harris everyone's been avoiding
not
you're so clever i had no idea that you
were taking your show off early last
time coming in today with your
pig pen peanuts i wish
you take those off for the velveteen
buttons
i don't know no one's
hey ethan ethan come on ethan why do you
have to bring on a guy who has
a 30th of the viewership of yourself
i've ever heard
so you have a guy with less viewers to
come on to debate him because you can
why don't you apparently he had to think
about it
hold on a second all right let me let me
let me hear what let me hear what pig
pen has to say here really quick fair
enough
um but ethan ethan look i i don't hold
on a second ethan that's because
initially i came out here to talk with
ethan ethan
come on man look the same reason that i
haven't ever had a conversation with sam
cedars the same reason that uh joe rogan
uh sam harris brett weinstein dave rubin
ben shapiro don't own anything it's
based on a lie
ethan just like you claiming my ethan
you claiming my booker reached out to
you ethan when you know that's not
true there's no one ducking you sam i've
never
sam sam i
sam why do you feel that anyone owes you
airtime when you have a 40th of the
audience and you've been doing the show
for 10 times as long as i think i think
that ethan has just given it to me
right i didn't ask him for it right
you've been begging for it for a long
time with everyone bigger than yourself
yeah he's found he can't build an
audience and so what happens is he
uploads 15 times more
has less than a 50th of the audience
well that's why he wants to debate you
is so he can build his
sam sam come on your audience yeah cares
that i only have a million subscribers
and you have what six or seven
let me answer can i answer your question
can i answer your question can i answer
your question
do you want me to answer your question
my audience would say sam who
just like joe rogan's audience and ben
shapiro's and dave rubin
now they all know who you are because
you had to shoehorn yourself into
another
powered show every
this is another lie this is another lie
let me let me clarify sam let me clarify
sam
the change in my mind everyone knows on
the show right we've had professors
early last week stephen if you're
because you're an idiot
and half of your staff doesn't like you
because i'm a die-hard fan yes it's
because she's
a die-hard fan i've had heard of you but
i just
met you congratulations sam cedars fans
right now i'm trying to talk with you
you're interrupting sam started the show
today
you bombarded my show under a false
pretense you claimed that everyone just
like you claimed that i ducked a debate
with you under a false pretense have i
ever
uh that is what the politicon people do
is that what they told you
so you're just lazy with your research
and if big tech
is you continue with the lie you need to
research did stephen ever accept
they let me let me explain to you let me
explain to you let me explain to you hey
hey hello
sam sam sam sam sweetheart
sam fake stand-up comic who we can't
find any footage about online let me
finish i'm not a stand-up comic
oh you're not okay that makes sense
because everything that i've seen is
incredibly
unfunny and unentertaining which may
explain the audience numbers
comedian comedian sam thank you can i
answer your question
appreciate it sam discussing sam samuel
can i answer your question
yes so you have gone on and you've done
the same thing with other other comments
everyone has a bigger audience than you
because you said i want to speak with
stephen crowder
you believe that at some point there was
some acceptance what have i ever done a
politicon
ever what about as a matter of fact in
the last decade
in the last decade in the last decade i
haven't done a single political
conference i hosted cpac for four years
and stopped because they suck
they don't pay and they're full of
losers
all right okay let's talk about this so
ethan do you want to have a conversation
ethan about
the vaccine because ethan do you want to
have a conversation you're going to hide
you felt so strongly about it so why are
you hiding behind san
san siddique have a conversation
well you're just a liar because remember
we said hold on a second hold on a
second
yeah it sort of feels like you guys are
the ones who are hiding
really hiding no no this is actually
you who's the guy who never appears on
stage never does a live show but it
never even
sheds it never even allows a shadow of
comedy to be perceived on his program
it's just hiding
everything we do is out in the open h3
h3 you know stephen
so hold on a second yeah so
i want to normalize responsible gun
ownership is that your debate no wonder
you had to bring in a hack for you want
to call it a
crying out lobster that was just the
main strategy
you have a holster bro you have a
holster as he takes advantage of
mentally
ill women for a show that just is
dwindling all right
okay all right sam you you you got it
you got it i hope you have a
uh i hope you have a wonderful highlight
reel hope you enjoy politics
i hope you
hey sam one thing before i go one thing
before i go can you take off your
glasses stephen one thing before i go
take off your glasses we just want to
see i just want to see if you take them
off if you have
if you have the velveteen rabbit buttons
that's the only thing i'm curious about
it's the only interesting part about it
or if there's a soul
just take off the take off the glasses
don't hide behind the glasses sam
don't say let's debate ethan you've lost
that uh
all right this is sad this is what we
don't think shut up
all right good you guys are good thank
you appreciate it won't even take off
the glasses
all right yeah you can uh you can get
the axe this is
i knew the guy just thought is that all
right the guy thought that no we're
still going the guy thought that we had
no i mean we have the master
at core black guy can you put on your
microphone yeah is he still on we have
the math no no i cut him off
we have the master file we knew yeah and
this is exactly what happens
like someone like a sam cedar who just
he didn't even wait he never lets you
speak
i like how he goes your little
leprechaun co-host because he's still
mad that i said he looked like a
transgender waning guy
you know that's just been eating at him
for the last month well you know and
this is the thing too
is um i don't do we don't do debates
based on a lie like i can call out mike
tyson i can call it a vendor it doesn't
mean anything right
and so when someone says hey you said
you would do this and you just
admitted that of course there's no proof
for that well i heard this from so and
so
yeah but there's no evidence we'll bring
up uh we can bring up here the direct
messages with
i hate to do this with ethan it was hey
we'll talk you and i
man no one else will come in matter of
fact i was gonna say if i have my phone
i can take a picture right here so
there's no prompter it's just
him on a on a call and he's terrified
i don't know how someone like that can
live their life as a man well people
just also talked very cordially to you
about
family oh yeah but what i really hate
about that is then he immediately pulled
it
which shows no character no class a
complete nephilim manipulation well he
look but here's
a show that's dwindling no one cares
about it so then he just he wants the
drama and i actually want to have a
conversation but i'm not going to have a
conversa
here's my cutoff a general serious rule
yeah
1 20th of the audience otherwise i have
no time in the day and i'm debating
every twitter egg well
right but here's my point of how you win
something very very easily your whole
point is as you're talking about
you have questions about right he claims
that something you don't even have to
think about
that's a bold statement to make so when
you go to challenge him on that his side
has to
explain why he feels that way so he
sneaks in another guy
because he doesn't have a holster bro
he's bought and paid for it
bro let me show you how to use it
you don't have to think about it dude
here's the thing i was really curious
too and then we'll go back to
the show i guess um i was really curious
from someone like like h3h3 who well you
know quarter black used to watch him
um made his bones i mean he has 15
million dollars worth of home
of real estate in los angeles he made it
all with anti-social justice warrior
content you know triggering feminists
snowflakes
and then and not only that but he was
more aggressive than me if you go back
and watch he talked about how he was
demonetized yeah
you know he used the word like 50 times
and with context just said i just love
saying the word
um which you know it's not really
couched in a joke no it's just him
saying it can you get millions of
dollars for that
i remember him back in the day and i
used to i didn't really like his content
but i remember i supported him or he
said hey
youtube should actually find a way to
monetize my content
that's edgier and older because networks
would be lining out the door for older
mail content so he was
actually more aggressive in fighting the
corporate censorship than me
and then one meeting with susan wojcicki
and he brags on a show about how he has
the youtube vp on
on text on speed dial and all of a
sudden he's saying
all lives matter is something that
people shouldn't be allowed to say
that our attack on him is bordering on
medical misinformation that
people should be deplatformed i don't
understand people change their mind
i'm really curious though when you see
someone who makes their entire living
who builds up their brain and their
empire on
anti-wokenness on anti-corporate
censorship who then does a 180 and
supports it at
every turn and i thought we would have
had a good opportunity to discuss that
specifically
ethan and myself not sam cedar because
you know ethan was the one who said
we should go with the cdc and world
health organization he was one of those
those are the big tech those are the big
tech guidelines ethan didn't debate you
for eight seconds no no he was
immediately like immediately
anybody quick quick quick to sam cedar
whatever
you know all right well i'll be honest i
never heard of till now not that it
matters if you've heard of anybody
but the only thing i've ever i i heard
of him because of the fact that he
started you know trolls with a lie that
i thought he was seth simmons that guy
who had
makes bird calls and said norm macdonald
wasn't i swear to god that's what i
thought it was the goodyear guy
yeah the guy who he got my friend shank
kicked off of snl
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's who i
thought it was i mean granted
it's kind to him but it's a different
person
i just think honestly i feel like it's
yeah it is kind of sad
um yeah it is kind of saturday well
here's an idea maybe just take the joke
that we turned it into a sound bite
yeah not being so pissed off well i
think they're going to be quite a few
more sound bites
of ethan on the soundboard so yeah maybe
sometimes uh let's uh
continue on with the kind of show that
uh someone like h3
would never be capable of doing not only
just that remember we provide references
for you
so on with the show
and now we're back to live it's like a
time lapse whoa oh my god so
there you go i think uh gerald that was
your first time that was i saw i was
watching it i i had to do the
unenviable task of watching their
version of events
yesterday and i'm not i don't know if
they did any like screwing around with
audio or anything but when i watched it
i couldn't hear you guys very well when
i watched this one i could hear you
there was definitely screwing around
without yeah so maybe because they're in
their studio so
maybe yeah there's a number of different
people i could also i could never see
him or really hear him aside from that
that's true
it's not obvious right so the whole time
i was thinking that you could
you got a gun holster bro you could see
him and what they were basically doing
he got hairbrush switching behind the
scenes so that they could put ethan back
on
right and make it look like they were
going back and forth so just to be clear
everybody
out there ethan was on there for what
you saw and then it was sam cedar for
what like
uh a little bit of time before you even
acknowledged his problem well there's
also there was a lag there's delay and
all this stuff
so yeah you know look this is also this
is why and you guys can comment below
this is the issue is just like i
i just don't want to have a debate based
on a lie yeah i mean like going on said
oh his his booker reached out to us says
h
no or oh stephen to the politic no it's
like i've
never wanted to do those things and this
whole thing i think
they were just saying like we had the
schedule no no it was me and ethan
and ethan just you know the biggest cell
phone honestly is that ethan has been
i'm an idiot bro i can't debate it's
like yeah but
you reached out to me today yeah bro
your whole thing was a lie i mean for
you to take for you to take that same
part would be like basically somebody
going up and interviewing the streaker
at a soccer match who's just like
please somebody look at me right that's
exactly what it was
but he made a point he said hey i've got
a million subscribers i mean what does
that mean
well i did so i did some research i was
like okay well like a million
you know a million more than i have so
fine we'll take a look at it it's not
what we do but fine
he has three percent of the viewership
with 17 times the amount of uploads so
just just to give you perspective
three percent of the viewership so it's
not like he's got a million people
watching his videos by the time we have
this one come out tomorrow
maybe a million yeah and a half views
and that's not the only thing i want to
be clear like i know we've i've debated
people who are professors people who are
experts
or it's gonna be an audience that's
somewhat comparable otherwise every
single tom dick and harry and exactly
would be taken
you know i think a general rule is and
i'm thinking of being generous like i
said a 20th
there you go of the audience just
because look i have a wife with twins
there's not so much time in the day
yeah but um it does take everybody wants
a shot at the champ well
yeah and i certainly wouldn't say champ
but it doesn't even really require you
know a journeyman well you don't like
ethan
[Music]
um and the saddest part about this is
that is it just me or did ethan just
like he's like you said i was a layup
yeah let me prove it
yeah yeah let me confirm right first
exactly and the only thing that they
have is like oh you didn't expect that i
was gonna bring on someone else
okay well that's exactly what i expected
only because the only thing that can be
expected of someone like
and this happens with a lot of people on
the left is just cowardice it's just
lies we've had this happen in the past
with debates where people
set a time and then don't show up and
then and that's just why we don't do it
all that much i'd like to do them live
like i said i would love to have
someone like noam chomsky in the show
yeah uh i would would have back in day
someone like a hitchens people who are
actually going to sit down and have
conversations and who are
experts right because debates like this
other guy wants to do
are basically just interrupting you and
who has the best one-liner in the moment
that's not how you put your viewpoints
out there that's how you try to score
points and try to get viewers by the way
i love that the entire time that they
were talking about this they're like oh
yeah he's just trying it's just
clickbait he's just throwing stuff out
for a quick pic
sam your entire gig is clickbait
challenging people that have audiences
multiple times higher than yours now
that we looked at the three percent
viewership rate you have
it's even worse and nobody is taking
you're like the girl
that just stalks a guy nobody wants to
date that no no no no no that's not fair
it's like a girl who stalks like uh 10
guys yeah
yeah that's like that's true it's not a
guy look i don't know
i understand he's trying to i understand
what he's doing yeah but he's got it
when he gets caught up
no but i him he's sort of chosen his
path and this is what he does
right i was really hoping you know
hoping for better from from ethan
you know that any time i've had someone
on the show who i disagree with i let
them know beforehand hey just so you
know
i disagree with you because i've had
journalists in the past whether it's
new york times right up or bloomberg
saying like no no it's unbiased look be
left be right just don't lie to me
right you can't find a single person on
the left who we just who listed among
the debate
who said like oh i didn't know right i
had no idea what i was what i was
walking into well you were so nice to
ethan and you kind of set it up like hey
man look i i disagree with you on these
things
right we're going to talk about i'm not
there's no gotcha moments nothing like
that and then immediately like zero
character ethan shows up well you know
and you guys can comment and you know
let me know what you think what point do
you owe someone
um a long long long form conversation
when it's
all predicated on a lot right yeah
exactly and by the way i i took some
offense
you've got a recovering alcoholic over
here who basically
yeah that's yeah
he said your co-host sounds like a drunk
when his co-host sounds like helen
keller learning water
but you're right i'm the one that's
finished yeah like a ventriloquist when
they drink the cup of water
yeah by the way and the peter pan guy
come on i did that once man
yeah well it was part of more costumes
it's what happens when you put effort
into a show i know i was also the mona
lisa
ethan what's most offensive in all of
this i've been the academy award trophy
right
i've been an oscar i don't know if i'd
want to watch his show or rather watch
uh two hours of the san francisco gay
chorus
san francisco gay chorus would be
straighter it's a toss-up
i'd rather watch two hours of my mom's
funeral
i'd rather pay for front row nickelback
seats
and again it would be more straight oh
far more oh and you think
something too he said what do you say to
dave you know it wasn't really
what was it your leprechaun yeah that
really hurts coming from a guy who looks
like he got too fat for his rollerblades
[Laughter]
that guy has a face christopher reeve
would punch
oh no seriously he
[Laughter]
he's got the nerve to talk about me he
looks like an aging toddler
have you noticed that like it the
the only like i saw this smug face of
his too
right where it's like it looked like a
mug shot of a guy who got arrested
with a sweatpants boner outside of jimbo
[Laughter]
that was me it's this it's just amazing
though it's these moments though where
they get they go after like candace
owens ben shapiro yourself
right and they do essentially nothing
and then they jump on top of it saying
they have these
dunkin moments where they owned the only
thing he's dunking is donuts
and i know that was too easy but you're
a fat piece of [ __ ]
so i just want to point out that what he
did yesterday though was pathetic
i sat here and watched it right all he
had to do was stand
on his own two feet and admit
what and and stand by what he said yeah
and instead
he snuck a guy on like he had a can of
peanuts with the worm and
the snake inside it's a gotcha and
you're like no we know it's in there you
[ __ ]
right it's a hack it's like hey take
this stick of gum
i i don't really chew gum don't you want
the gum come on
i don't want to don't you he's adjusting
the trap here's some gum
for you bro and isn't he worth like
millions of dollars oh yeah yeah he has
like a well and that's that's why does
he dress like a ghetto ant
going to vegas
[Music]
i guess the pre-show roundup of taking
the high road uh oh i'm not taking that
no no no no well you know dave is gonna
be dave
[Laughter]
he looks like they fished andy dufresne
out of the river of [ __ ]
so after a couple of weeks oh what a
mess and yeah i've been sober for
over 10 years yeah thank you yeah yeah
which is fine
i mean you can think that i drink i wish
i drank because i really liked it at the
time yeah i just couldn't it might
soften the edge and having to watch this
it really would help me get through
anything he says
but keep wearing what is the t what's
his hat tf
what's the chief what is that uh is it
total
total failure total band on youtube oh
yeah
oh
and then running around twitter telling
everybody that he that he wanted
a victory lap good for you yeah i don't
you know that's also
the thing that is very that is worrisome
is um you know we do have to go on we
have
donald trump uh junior on you know the
president's and again not not hunter
biden there was a difference
yeah you make it at home along with
along with yogurt
um you know he had ethan also like we
said we didn't really know until
afterwards obviously like the sound was
manipulated that you know they were
doing some switching
um but something else that isn't that i
did know going in was that he did
say that our segment on his comments on
the cdc was bordering on medical
misinformation right and so this also
was really hard it's not really even
footing when you have someone like ethan
who
who supports the over the banning of
people the d platforming the censorship
which he was vehemently against for a
very long time
it's like look i can't even correct the
record with what my opinions are because
we know that those are impermissible and
he supports that and that's always weird
to me like everyone changes their mind
but when you change your rezone diet
where you make your money and your bones
with anti-social justice warrior stuff
and then you switch
um and that's yeah same thing you know
he has he has significantly uh fewer
views and we do overall on this show but
like you're talking about the revenue
well we're demonetized we're pretty open
about that
and he has like 15 million dollars worth
of home you know and yeah which is good
good for him
but the issue there is you know because
he's had susan wojcicki there's so
people out there know what this is just
like
the vox it wasn't about vox it was about
nbc yeah and he's uh did you say one of
them was on speed now like the vice
president
yeah he's no he's bragging he hasn't
bragged in the past and his
he just had this drama too with this
girl who who has and i don't say this to
insult a girl named trish peters who's
like mental health disorders yeah
self-declared like bipolar and
schizophrenic and this guy ethan hired
her to exploit her
and he's talked about with her on air
how he has the youtube vp on speed dial
and how
he's he has the ability to get people
banned oh my god so that's always what
it is it's always difficult when it's
like it's based on a lie you know people
are trying to get you to say something
that gets you banned
and we want to have an actual
conversation about these ideas i would
love to talk about the cdc i would love
to talk about the emergency cdc meeting
with uh myocarditis you know uh
myocardia whatever it is now with
the vaccine i would love to talk about
how they were wrong about asymptomatic
carriers about children being carriers
about it not being a
a lab leak about masks after vaccination
i'd love to have these conversations you
just never get to no
and that's the reason for it change my
mind because you get to have those
conversations as opposed to scoring
points well with that i think people
should realize there was no construct
there was no uh constructive angle or
any sort of a conversation in what
happened yesterday
that's why the call was pulled off it
was uh nothing and there was
no reason to stop it was a gotcha yeah
you know we're surprised
about the cdc we're not talking about
big tech we're talking we wanted to
discuss
you get people de-platform right which
is always a pro it's always weird to me
yeah
except it's not weird when you
understand that it's like you know i
want to take get mine and then remove
everybody else
uh hey a girl tested positive for a pork
burrito
ah moving on how is that possible shelby
uh
shelby houlihan houlihan suzanne sucks
okay
nope slap shot i didn't know they
stacked [ __ ] that high
shelby houlihan brought me no this is a
woman and i to be fair she may not have
taken steroids okay
actually because she's passed a
polygraph and she had a hair sample but
here's what's interesting here
i think all women should be allowed to
take steroids and all men for the
olympics with the exception of one year
and i'll explain it to you
so she's the record holder in the 1500
and 5000 meter runs
okay um and she's been banned for
competition now for four years
wow wow after testing positive for the
anabolic steroid known as
nandralone and i think we have um a clip
this is a big story
right now but there's a bigger story
behind it with the international olympic
committee
on january 14 2021 i received an email
from the athletics integrity unit
the aiu informing me a drug testing
sample that i provided on december 15
patches just a little too close to the
ss logo for country
i know it's not on purpose for a steroid
called angelone gotta stay away from
light
learned that it has been long understood
by wada the world
anti-doping agency that eating pork can
lead to a false positive from angelorn
we concluded that the most likely
explanation was a burrito purchased and
consumed
approximately 10 hours before that drug
passed from an authentic
mexican food truck i received the news
that the court of arbitration
did not accept my explanation of what
had occurred and has subsequently banned
me from the sport
for years now either her excuse is true
or she just
uh in an incredibly racist way through
mexican food trucks
in an authentic mexican food truck what
i mean is no white people
were involved and just even really need
to clarify purchase
i purchased and consumed burrito all
right we don't need to be so flowery
with the language you ate a burrito
yeah same thing happened to lance
armstrong yes exactly yeah
yeah well i believe in a row i believe
it was two burritos but now it's just
one right yeah
lost one really more of a chimichanga
yeah yeah which is basically the same
thing so sports illustrated
she had a positive test of five
nanograms per milliliter of nandrolone
again which said this from a tainted
pork burrito because pigs naturally have
uh high levels i didn't know this of
angelo
by the way hey right now you can share
this if you're watching this live
sharing
is caring right so when you hit that
share button you can post it on facebook
you can post it on twitter because
all across the spectrum we don't get we
don't get the youtube browser
you'll feel good about yourself for
sharing yeah um so
i don't know if she did steroids or not
okay i don't care
i think that everyone should be allowed
to do steroids and let the games begin
why because that's what they're doing
now right so this is something that no
one else has talked about
with the ioc is international olympic
committee right or is it commission
anyway committee the ioc is it committee
yeah that's what mitt romney gosh now i
say that all right now you got me
confused
she's incompetent she's taking
testosterone and nandra loaning
committee
oh yeah she got a third nipple
and a fifth nut oh
somebody had a pull pluck slider or
dozens first i get injected into the ass
before i move my way through the
bloodstream
and grow an extra large love numb
congratulations bill now you're a ball
oh yeah so
so she won't be allowed to compete
because of a very small elevated level
of nandrolone and i understand that's a
problem
okay but you know who will someone who's
been using steroids their entire life
they're called testicles laurel hubbard
laurel hubbard
it produces the male olympic weight
lifter from new
zealand wow and i want to be really
clear about this too so
the timeline here matters so that you
understand you know i've said that
really reprehensible behavior from
people in the lgbtq aips
deemed acceptable just because people
are afraid of the mob
echoed that so laurel hubbard a man
competed was not very good as a male
competitive lifter surprise then decided
that he would compete as a
as a female um and won some notable
uh tournaments like the samoan or the
polynesian games i guess is a big deal
something like new zealand nationals
then snapped a ligament in his in in in
z's arm i'm not trying to do this here
i'm just trying to make sure i get
through this but i'm looking at the
picture of the guy from the goonies
and snapped it in his elbow in her elbow
and uh
we all know what happens there when you
alter a man's hormone levels lower their
testosterone increase estrogen
your ligaments become tissue paper now
here's the deal
the ioc when they say that men can
compete with women you would think okay
there are certain metrics that have to
be met no
it's one it's only one and you have to
prove
that your testosterone levels as a man
competing against women
uh that they are as low as a female's
testosterone levels
for one year that's it that's the only
requirement
one year and it's actually not even
as uh as uh strict as that let me be
clear about this too
uh laurel hubbard retired after the
injury yeah
laurel hubbard just came back out and
said i'm going to compete at the
olympics
has not been in that testing pool for a
year this happened in the ufc when brock
lesnar left the ufc right there was a
usada testing pool
left went to the wwe they announced him
coming back and it was a big deal
because the rules said you had to be in
the drug testing pool for a year
to make sure that you're not using
steroids and he came back larger and
leaner than when he was ufc champions
yeah like the rock
all natural yeah beat the hell out of
mark hunt tested positively
and then left yeah so this this so
laurel hubbard hasn't been
in the testing pool for long enough what
would be my bet okay hurt my ligaments
hurt my joints
get back on some gear or really just
allow my balls to work
then come in you know for six months and
beat the [ __ ] out of women but it's
worse than that
you think testosterone levels of a woman
for one year
yeah now i've looked through the entire
ioc guidelines i have a mirror
yeah yes it doesn't even talk
no just a standard basic mirror it says
really bad stuff but it's just
still me talking mirror mirror on the
wall who's the fairest of them all and
the mirror just goes
um i don't know a lot of people
it goes equality do you want me to lie
or are you gonna shatter me
we're all the same because i'm a woke
mirror right
so uh you'd think the testosterone
levels of the female look through the
ioc rules okay
here's what it says the testosterone uh
the serum level has to be below
10 nanomoles per liter okay now here's
the thing people look at that and go
well that's really low if any of you out
there by the way comment below any men
or women who've had your testosterone
tested yeah like for most men the
average level is between
300 and i think the upper end is like
1100. that's what they allow in the ufc
the 250 depending you know what i mean
like
they might treat you for low
testosterone but that's typically the
measurement
now for women that's about 15 to 46 and
so you
read this and you say oh so the
international they're actually being
more harsh right
has to be as low as 10 but then you
realize they're using some international
conversion unit that is not what anyone
use on their blood test
they're saying it has to be below 10 i
believe nanomoles per liter
what you all use is uh nana nanoliters
per deciliter
nanograms per deciliter sorry nanograms
per deciliter so i went to my doctor and
converted the number
that they are using and that actually
would number what you would see in a
blood test
285 i believe 288
so in other words laurel hubbard to
compete with women only has to
prove for a year in this case maybe six
months that his
testosterone level is only 10 times that
of a natural female are you kidding me
no i'm not kidding
10 times out of a natural female so if a
woman were actually a nandrolone
pork burrito it still wouldn't wouldn't
even be discernible compared to the
difference of
10 times the testosterone level of a
woman and that's just for that year
outside of that it's probably 20 30
times the level
all the years leading up to well by the
way if all of you got on steroids right
now
and i didn't you still wouldn't enjoy
the performance advantage over me
that laurel hubbard is allowed to enjoy
into competition for that year
and no one's talking about it i'm just
trying to get off him you know
well i think he's tired the guy's in the
mid in his mid 40s i think
i'm sorry the hubbard isn't in their mid
40s
sucks right that person is in their
mid-40s right and i think they were
competing as a man until
i think 2014 2011 something like that so
so i'll give him a decade right
her i'll give them a decade and say
you've been competing your entire
life this isn't like a 21 year old
person this even even though the
argument could still be made
this is somebody who's been doing this
in their entire life and this is
specifically something where you're
lifting heavy objects which we know
men do better on average an exact
comparison
this would be the if
not lately it depends if i really don't
want to move
i just you know higher was it chicks
moving bricks whatever it is like
hotties moving boxies
yeah here's your shattered glass table
sorry about your couch whoops
but we just you break my crystal
elephant what gives
she drop it in my indoor outdoor pool
again
um this would be the exact to give you
an exact comparison
it would be the equivalent to a man
being allowed to you know
in the olympics call it wrestling call
it weightlifting take steroids his
entire
like every single steroid right right
yeah nandra alone i don't know what the
nandra nandrolone uh uh whatever the
other ones are whatever they test
positive for
all of the above designer steroids and
extra testosterone
for 20 years and then say okay but
leading up
to the olympics for one year i'm only
going to take
a testosterone supplement that gives me
10 times the level of a normal man
that's what it is and so i am saying
that if the international olympic
committee wants to be consistent with
this
and you guys comment and let me know
what you think i think the only way to
be consistent is to let every single
competitor
use steroids as much as they want
outside of one year
and then they can use half a steroid
right and the female
lifter i think another power lifter has
come out and said this is just a joke
like this this is absolutely a joke this
is not a sport that's fair
anymore so i i think uh hopefully they
will fix this but i doubt it
yeah i don't i mean they're going to
look they're going to look bad and they
don't want to look bad
hey you guys just let me know are you
guys waiting to get uh donald jr on the
phone
okay let me know we got him yeah uh did
you watch the footage of this
olympic lifter i did yeah how disturbing
on a scale of one to ten
oh boy an 11 yeah a spinal tap 11.
definitely turn it i'm going to go with
that and laurel hubbard is coming out
now
preparing some people use smelling salt
some people chalk up she is doing her
infamous i'd [ __ ] me dance
she's powdering her balls i saw the uh
the babylon bee tweet yesterday talking
about a terrible turn of events for ioc
olympic
lifter has suffers a terrible testicle
injury
this is just this is just awful for
women sporting all around but one hell
of an ad for gold bond
look it keeps it chafing away
wonderful all right so look before we
bring on our next guest uh if we have
him available in quarterback
you can bring it up here so i can see
him the son of the president again
hunter biden at the cheese convention so
what i mean is we have donald trump jr
but
um before we have him on i think we have
a clip of donald trump jr released a
video this week
which was just perfect disgus perfect
that sounds like my mom
my mom it's perfect stephen uh
perfect talking about uh putin and biden
the summit so let's go to the clip
before we bring him on joe biden
in a presser after his meeting with
putin says that he gave
putin a list of things that are off
limits
to russian cyber attacks 16 of them
16 things the other stuff you know have
at it guys
yeah all right so now let's bring on of
course none other than donald trump jr
[Music]
what's going on guys well i'm doing very
well i need to give you your plugs the
books are
liberal privileged and triggered and you
only sent me one of them still
uh but uh you're on twitter at donald
trump
jr you wrote a bunch of books and how
many books did you was it quarantined
that you wrote like another two
no no i wrote triggered uh you know
before quarantine ever happened and then
you know while quarantine was happening
i had all this sort of extra free time
because you know
you couldn't go to this you couldn't go
out you couldn't leave the house so i
said let's let's look at joe biden since
the media
used to do that job yeah they refused to
do it so i did and
man it's sort of hard to believe i feel
like i had a crystal ball it's almost
like all of this information about bite
and corruption
weakness towards foreign uh adversaries
like russia and china uh
the sun uh the racism
uh all of it it was almost like it was
out there stephen yeah it was almost
like
he had a 50 year career in washington
and people could look it up for
themselves but
because the media refuses to do the
basic tenets of their stated job
someone had to do it so i did it and
yeah i was right about all of it there's
a lot of crystal ball stuff going around
now are people predicting things i mean
hey look maybe in the next quarantine
you'll be able to do uh you know a
lesson on how to put it in landscape
mode
so um but let me let me ask you this
this is the point that i made uh uh um
mr trump jr i never know what to call
you because it's like your dad can still
squash my nuts into oblivion and i want
to be respectful but
with russia and there was a lot of
criticism with your father versus russia
in the administration and i always said
he was a little more complimentary than
i liked however
the big difference if you look at it was
a historical moment for example with
your dad and north korea
cross the border but he sat there at the
table
with a plan for a deal that was
denuclearization when it didn't happen
he walked same thing with russia he was
complementary but negotiating from
position of strength whereas biden
talked a lot saying he's a killer and
then cow towed and negotiated from
a position of weakness two diametrically
opposed way
of handling it being complimentary being
nice and carrying a big stick
um that's what stands out most to me
what was it
what was it like you know in your house
when you were guys were doing this with
stuff with russia back in the day it
must have been
incredibly hard to navigate because the
media was in a witch hunt
well it was nonsense i mean you see it
so what were the end results
under trump the sanctions on russia were
higher than they had ever been
in the history of the two nations right
i think we can all say that's fair and
agree on that
under joe biden what they get they got a
big pipeline that's billions of dollars
a year in revenue
they got uh they they're pulling uh you
know an aid
package a military arms aid package from
the ukraine that's a huge win for russia
when they inevitably try to take over
the rest of ukraine
uh so donald trump when he basically
wouldn't talk smack on a world stage
which would accomplish nothing because
he's a business guy he understands how
the real work world works
if he takes the cheap shot at putin on
the world stage it actually accomplishes
nothing it gives the media a little bit
of their fonder but then when something
actually happens when something actually
matters
you've now burned that bridge you can't
pick up the phone and have that
conversation so he didn't take
this sort of cheap shot biden will do
that because he's not capable of doing
the other things
so he'll take the cheap shot the media
gives him a fictitious win
and then he folds on everything else
giving russia
billions of dollars in revenue with
nordstrom 2. uh you know maybe hunter's
on the board there may be 10 maybe more
percent for the big guy who the hell
knows
uh you know but that's the difference
because the media doesn't function in
the real world they don't understand how
real things
actually happen they just like to preach
um
you know from this like fictitious uh
disney princess
world that no one actually lives in so
they wanted to ride trump for not
just trying to destroy putin on a world
stage but what would it
actually have got you think it's going
to change putin no no it just makes it
harder to actually get something done
when you actually need something to get
done yeah i feel like but
um former vice president joe biden is
like one of those guys at the gym who
walks around a tank top and fictitious
lat spread but it's like
we're gonna see you walk up to the
pull-up or and you can't do them
so like just stop why do this beforehand
you see those guys they got their music
on i got got my when you're having a
trouble
i think he walks through chuck e cheese
like that you know we're not going to
believe that you're a power lifter right
yeah and i want to ask you something
specific though i want to ask you
something really specific because i feel
like this is in your wheelhouse um
this was what stood out to me to a lot
of people well we're talking about
former vice president biden being weak
um you're you're dead to the best of my
never did anything like this
he said he gave putin a list
specifically of 16 things
not to hack i thought that was a fake
headline
at first um i was like
is this the babylon b because i mean
first of all
like okay these are the have at it the
other
50 000 things that are part of our
critical infrastructure you guys can
play around with that i mean it's such
a weak move it's so pathetic
and by the way what was worse was did
you see the the
media said you know look putin says that
joe biden seemed very sharp in the
meaning
of course he did you think putin's dumb
enough he wants to negotiate against
someone sharp he's going to build up
fighting because he wants to be
at the negotiating with biden for the
rest of eternity right that's how and
the media doesn't say anything about it
they assume
oh no no putin's being a hundred percent
serious he thinks biden's at the top of
his
game yeah you know imagine trump got a
compliment
like that from putin and the response
it's just
we're living in bizarro world uh and
it's playing out before our very eyes
well and for him even you know harris is
too extreme he's like i don't want her
in charge they put people with drug
offenses to slave labor camps to build
roadways and put out fires i mean
think about it vladimir putin is owning
you know the american policy on some of
these things and the insanity
he's literally able to go out there and
have fun with how stupid
this administration is and you know
again there's total media silence on it
but
you know hopefully people like ourselves
can get that information out there
it is it's really sad and then i wanna
gerald has a question and then we're
gonna have to go to mug club here and
then let him really rip but yeah
gerald what was your question here for
uh for the don well so your video said
that like okay so what was the 17th
thing on the list but not only that can
you imagine being in business
and going to all your competitors and
saying here are the 16 essential things
about our business by the way
make sure you don't do anything like
this to compete with us i think putin's
sitting there with like his notebook
like yes
oh i forgot i forgot to list accounting
i
thought we had counter intelligence but
like you're supposed to keep that a
secret joe you might as well just give
them the nuke codes
[Music]
hey by the way you played a few seconds
of it but that was like a five to seven
minute rant on how stupid this is but
yeah 100
so you highlight to your enemies these
are the things that are really really
important to us
these are perhaps our weak things these
are the
perhaps the things that would make it
really hard for us to respond
back so please please pretty please
don't don't mess with those and again
it's like giving them a permission slip
to mess with the rest of it the other 50
000 things like if you do that
we're not going to counter attack we're
not going to push back
we're going to let we're just going to
roll over and die like everything else
that we do
with our adversaries i mean putin is
loving it it's why he's complimenting
joe biden on a world stage
the media says you know it's because joe
biden's so sharp
like does anyone believe that like is
there anyone at this point in world
history
like i mean is the media truly not
the enemy of the people at this point
well i blame it because i think a lot of
the media you know they're just they're
they're they're barren hacks because
anyone who has a kid knows that trick
like when my dad or my my mom might go
softer on me and send me to my room and
i knew i wasn't getting a spanking i'd
be like
what what no not my room ah
damn it i have to the super nintendo in
there where i play video games for the
next eight hours i would
hate that couldn't you please just give
me the belt and be over with i guess
i'll go okay all right well
this game boy is not gonna play itself
bye mom it's a great
analogy because that's what it's like i
mean you're dealing with like
a president who is basically has the
functional capabilities of a child again
we have him out there
on the world no but like seriously look
you had boris johnson
right he's shutting him down because
biden was trying to correct him
because he didn't remember that boris
johnson introduced
you know the president of south africa
like 30 seconds before
and boris was like shut up joe get to
the court i know i know i know
don't play with your toys like shut up
joey i already did that
the entire g7 was laughing at him and
then you saw the other time joe tried
interjecting and they're just like
talking a hand joe just just
shut up and be you know the wallflower
the media will spawn all over you just
do us a favor and don't open your mouth
because you're going to embarrass
yourself and by association you're going
to embarrass us
they're doing that to him on a world
stage look at the pictures
you know of macron pointing that was my
question to you what would have happened
in his lunch
what do you think your dad would have
done it's disgusting don
what do you think your dad would have
done if you know a frenchman got in his
face like this
seriously what do you think would have
happened
because it would never have happened
stephen they would never do that to him
because they know
look at like look at the videos from
last year's g7
you had trump sitting there like this
and angela merkel's at the desk he's
laughing at her yeah
her face because he's got all the cards
and he knows it and they know it but the
same clowns like in germany where
no no we want the russian pipeline it's
like and they also want us
to pay for the nato defenses right joe
biden said
that the eu is the backbone of nato we
pay 70 of the nato budget 70
right we what do we get from it nothing
so we pay 70
we we are supposed to protect germany
and the other eu countries
in nato from the enemy that they are
enriching with a pipeline and like no
one thinks that this is insane like this
no it's totally good so joe biden says
the eu is the backbone of nato no
we're the backbone of nato [ __ ] you're
paying for all of it they're the
backbone of
nato like uh bernie sanders catches most
of the bill it's like
i got it like really you're gonna leave
your 12 tip to the number
okay hey look uh you're obviously people
can follow you on twitter the book
is triggered is that the most recent one
the book really quickly liberal
liberal privilege just okay liberal
privilege and i want to keep talking
with you we're going to talk about uh
the rallies coming up and also the lab
leak but lab leak you have to be careful
here on youtube so
we're here with donald trump jr if you
are not a mug club member consider
joining
youtube thank you but uh you know what
to do
[Music]